[音楽]
いつの日かこのナンバーがニューヨークパリー
なんば世界にたんの通った街になるように活動しています
こんな私に街づくりプロデューサーなんてかっこいい名前つけていただいて本当に
ありがとうございます
改めて皆さんこんにちは
私の名前は待ちか横43歳
[音楽]
もうちょっと若く見えるって思われたいんですけどね今で女好きはそんなもんかなって
いうかをでした
a 10歳の娘の母でございます
私はどういう会社をしてますかということなんですけども
外国人におもてなし例えばお好み焼き屋さんだったらお好みや焼き方を教えたり
メニューを多言語化したりそして
地図を作ったりこれを外国語で表記するような仕事なんかを15
年やっております
どんだけ難波の人間というような感じしますけど私別にナンバーで生まれ育った訳じゃ
ありません
皆さん最近ちょっと有名になってます
大阪万博の近く舞洲夢洲の近くの軟膏というところで育ちました
全難波に縁もゆかりもなかったんです
じゃあ何でこのナンバーに縁もゆかりのない私がこのナンバーに関わることになったん
でしょうか
それは実は15年前にある小さな新聞記事を読んだことがきっかけだったんです
その新聞記事には平成の拳闘士募集
南活性化委員会と一緒に上海いこうと書いてたんです
うわぁ
ただで上海ける
ただそれだけの理由で応募しようと思ったんです
遣唐使ってちょっとピンとこないかもしれませんが
中国に初めて日本人で行った留学生みたいなイメージでいいと思います
レッスンで私もその小さな記事で論文を書いてくださいということだったので
中国に行ってあんなことがしたいこんなことがしたい
日本と中国の架け橋になりたいっていう思いをつづったんです
おかげさまでありがとうございます平成の検討し見事合格でございます
その時に南のたくさんの人たちと一緒に上海に行くことになったんです
そこから私がみなみと関わることになりました
の中の一人に
日本抜粋商店街というところの会長さんがいましてその方の歯医者は
この電子部品の会社だったんです
電子分院の会社って言ってもロボットとか
真空管に興味のある人以外はほとんど興味がないようなそういう部品の会社だったん
ですね
その会社の社長会長に呼ばれまして
僕ねー
分かってんねん
お父さんが一生懸命電子部品探しているお母さん横で1時間2時間見ててめちゃくちゃ
楽しと楽しくない顔してる
その時にその方は地図を作ったんです
お母さんこっちねちょっと喫茶てあるからそこでお茶飲ん時とか
子供ちゃんにも近所にね公営あるからそこで遊ん時お父さんはそのか何時間でも電子
部品を探せる時間ができたんです
こういうことをしている人たちがこの街には
いでたんです
その方との出会いで私は
中国語の地図を作らせていただける機会をいただいたんです
15年前の
このナンバー大阪のことちょっと知ってるという方はいらっしゃるかもしれませんけど
も
トンド外国人観光客いてなかったんです
まして中国ですよ
ビザも取れないほとんど来ないところになぜ中国語の地図を作るのか
その方が佳境の方だったんです
いつかきっと中国の方がこの街に溢れることになる
その前に中国をの地図をつくろうと言ってくださったんです
ここで私のプチ自慢です
中国の大学を卒業しています
日本で中国の大学を卒業してる子っていうのはその当時はすごく少なかったんです
ですから一緒に地図作らせてくださいというふうに
聡さんとお話をさせて頂いてお仕事を受けることにしました
中国をの地図を作るのに半年間かかりました
でもがむしゃらでしたその当時の地図ちょっと詳しく見てください
ありえない
公衆電話のかけ方書いてます切符のかけ方も帰って母の飼い方も書いてます
当時こんなにスマートフォンが普及するなんて思っても見てませんでした
電話だって国際電話家計の大変だろうと思ってそういうことを
地図の中にたくさん入れ込んだんです
半年間働いていただいたお給料
皆さん心の中で想像してみてください
私ちなみに大卒です
半年働きました
いくらだったでしょうか
10万円いただきました
これが皆さんとって多いのか少ないのかは別として私はこの10万円がすごく大切なお
金になったんです
その時に卵場合というのが生まれたんです
というのもこの地図を作る時は私はナンバーに何のご縁もありませんでしたから
とにかくがむしゃらにこの街を歩き歩いたんです
面白い事があるんやろうこの街でどんな街なんやろうと
半年間歩きまくって気づいたんです
まず日本バス商店街でんでんタウンという通称がありますが
電気の街とアニメの街といわれます
黒もう一羽商店街せいぜい食品の街で言われています
道具安井商店街プロの人たちがプロの道具を買いに行く商店街です
恵比寿ば数商店がアクセサリーであったりとか
靴であったりとかいろんなものはカエル商店が
そして道頓堀商店街食と園芸の商店が
なんとこの商店街
すべてナンバーを中心に徒歩5分圏内にある
こんなとこありますか
私初めて知ったんです
あおもろい町今までなんでもっと嫉妬がなかったんだろう
これや
その時またあの方の合言葉を聞きました
合言葉はこの町の人たちはみんな
設けたろーっと思うでしょ
おもろい今年ような
設けたろうっていうのは全然合言葉じゃなかった
おもろいことしよう
街が死んでしまったら僕たち私たちの商売できへんよな
まちが元気な時こそおもろい今年はないか
これが難波の魅力だったんです
なんとこの何倍に渡し日が次いだどころかアホな事してしまいました
実はこれをきっかけに自分の全財産叩いて会社を起こしてしまったんです
を起こしてしまったんです
若い子真似したいけません
皆さんのご想像の通り
語学がちょっと喋れたぐらいで会社を起業しても何の仕事が入ってきませ
なんと仕事も入ってきません
いこっちゃという感じです
その時に助けてくれたのが一緒に会社を起業した
飲食店の一人料理にの一人とデザイナーの一人だったんです
そして私が社長させていただいたんです
しかししかし
社長の私は全く仕事を取ってきません
立ってないんですも仕事があ
当時料理人だった彼はこのエリアのところで飲食をやってくれ
デザイナーさんは神の仕事がたくさんまでありましたから
デザインをやってくれたんです
で私は語学が得意この3人が同じ土俵に立つなんて想像しないまま会社を黄と青起こし
たんですね
どうしよう会社起こしたけど前に近いシャ行ってもやることないしなぁ
その時
私ボランティアで中国語を教えることを考えた
そして a
まあまだ来てない外国人観光客がの
この待ちでしたけどもいろんなところで中国をを精査せていただいていつか来るように
なりますから
いつか使うようになりますからボランティアでやってるんやから
食べ物暗い内のレストラン来てくれませんか
チラシぐらいちょっと家で作らさせてくれませんか
なんて少しずつ営業させていただきましてなんとか
ぼちぼちやれるようなところまで持ってこれた
さあ
そこで私の中でもう一つ
宝貝だけじゃなくてこの街で何かしたい
この町の地域に恩返しがしたいという思いが湧いてきたんです
それが裏なんばとの出会いだったんです
ちょうど飲食店等がポツポツポツってある
この東側のあたりになるんですけどこのウラなんばっていうのがやっと
a 数軒の飲食店が出てきた
その時に
一軒のラーメン屋の店主からトントンと私の会社にノックされた
なんですかっていうと
僕この街を盛り上げたいと思ってるんですけど
一緒に協力してくれませんかって言われたんです
oe ですよ
ただその当時の私は企業であったり
商店街であったり9地域の飲食の方との関わりはすごく少なかったんです
商店街そして企業そして地域
この3つが重要だということは分かっていたんですけれどもなかなかこの3つを
つなげることができなかったんです
ウラなんばっていう名前私名付けあではありません
でもすごく気に入ってるんですこの名前
ですから自分が今まで活動してきた商店街や企業にもこの名前を広めてくださいという
ふうに言いに行ったんです
ある方にそれを言うと
ちょっとここおきなさい
何ですか
裏って何やって言われ
暗すぎる
この街のイメージが悪なるやめてくれ裏なんばなんか
ホンダ何中断前にしたらいいんですの
華蘭ばデーなぁ
ああああああああ
はちょっと粉花ですか
明日花ハナランマンしてくれいやそれはちょっと
裏って本当に暗いイメージですか
裏切らないとか裏原とかなんかワクワクするような言葉ちゃいますか
一生懸命いろんな人にそれを訴え続けたんですん
そうするとやはりこの町の人たちはあったかいもんで
じゃあ一緒に雲やないかということで
バルをやると企業が協賛をつけてくれまして一緒にこう
盛り上げてくれましたしそして道具や水産
このお隣申すありますけれども道具や水産はプロの動画売ってますけど
料理に売ってないんですね
ですから一緒にコラボして裏なんばの料理民が商店街を盛り上げたりということで
やっと
商店街と企業とそして地域
この3つが一緒になってやり始めたんです
すごくうれしかった
これ一番最初に裏ナンバー
ラーメン屋の店主が持ってきたもう一枚しかないけどこの地図なんです
たった11店舗ロコの11店舗から始まった
ウラなんばが今では
にて2号3号と地図ございますが少し他の地図と違うのは飲食店だとどうしても料理の
会ね写真であったりとか看板の写真があると思うんですけども
ウラなんばは店主の顔
店主に会いにくる街裏なんばということを広めたかったんです
それと皆さん今日億倍している手元にある地図なんですけども
もう増えすぎまして
数がも日ラストじゃないと間に合わなくなりまして
今ではイラストをモチーフにさせてもらったウラなんばの地図を作っております
さあ裏面も工夫をさせていただいて今日のお話の sdg ずであったり
万博のお話なんかも入れさせていただいております
そんな時です
7年間裏ナンバーの地図を作りました
やっと私の時代がきたんです
これがインバウンドブームでございます
黒門市場行かれたことあるという方いらっしゃいますか
は10年前のクロムは
はがありますねこれ10年前のくろもんです
人っ子ひとり歩いてません
今みてください
現在のクローンはこんな感じでございます
pop はすべて英語
おじいちゃんおばあちゃん身売りで接客する
そして歩いてたら異国の地みたいな感じの黒もう一番になりました
それだけちゃうんですなんと日本バスで商店街ももうすごい人ですね
道具屋筋商店街どうブールだけちゃいます
体験までさせます
そして道頓堀商店街まるで usj
ねえ
グリコにハイタッチして見えるでしょ
火木にぶら下がっているように見えるでしょ
これ全部はたちゃんとそこの社長に許諾もうてますから
はい
まあ行こういう街になったわけです
これもいんば運の方々のおかげであり共存共栄できる楽しい街ナンバーだからです
それだけでは終わりません
私この人たちに何かお土産ものを持って帰ってもらいたいと思ったんです
どうしたええかな
一番 a のはやっぱり大阪弁やということで
大阪学習帳というのを作りました
この学習帳枚柄が勉強だ蹴るだけじゃなく
a 案とかなんでやねんっていうのを英語表記して
町名にしております
表りありますのでまた良かったみてください
方からまで作っちゃいました
はい
でこの方々の方々兵に乗ってるのは南の主要な飲食店の方々にご協力をいただいて金は
出さへんけど顔だけ貸してというような形で彼をお借りして作っております
ひらがなもカタカナも作りました
それでもまだ飽き足らないんです
旅するガチャが者ガチャガチャた庇だろうということで中のカプセルにナンバーのこと
をいっぱい詰め込んだり大阪べを詰め込んだりしてこんなも作っちゃいました
さあみてください
この qr コードをスキャンすると私の声でなんでやねんってできます
そしてレアキャラの赤色のが一つだけありますこれは娘の声でめっちゃスキャ年って
いうふうに立ってます
今日娘きてますから生の声をまた今度聞いてあげてください
はい大阪ナンバーのぬりえまで作ってしまいました
とにかくスーツケースステッカー作ったり
ナンバーを広めるためにありとあらゆるものを作ってるんですが
全部
自腹です
でも
自腹で作っても世に広めてくれない人ってたくさんいていると思うんです
しかしこのナンバー違います
大脆いや広めた老爺
ということでいろんな人たちがいろんな場所でこのおもろいを広めてくれております
私助かりました
ですからいつの日かこの街がニューヨークパリ難波になるようになってほしい
こればかり言っております
ニューヨークパリナンバー
かっこいいでしょう覚えました皆さんニューヨークパリナンバーですよ
もう一つだけ今日
新しい言葉をみなさんに広めていただきたいんです1つ
ニューヨークって
ニューヨーカーって言うでしょカッコような s かニューヨーカーてー
パリーパリジェンヌと言うでしょ
じゃあナンバーって何したええかなってすごい迷ったんです
アガリアンっていう言葉がありましてね
未開人とか野蛮人みたいな言葉なんですけども
未開人の方ちょっと撮らせていただいて私は
難波リーアンっていうのをやりたいなあと思ってます
皆さん今日この私のスピーチを聞いていただいて
ナンバーが好きになったらこれ一緒におもろいことしたいな
一緒にやろうやないかっていうふうに思っていただけたら今日から皆さんも
ナンバーリアになってください
そしてそこでた瞬間に俺何バリアでって言ってください
街づくりって本当に楽しいものです皆さんとって今日どういうふうに感じていただいた
かわかりませんがこんなカッコイイプロデューサーなんて言う名前なんて私には
もってのほかでございます
だけど夢はありますニューヨークパリナンバー皆さんランバリアーになっていただく
ことを夢見ておりますありがとうございました
ほんま扇リー
[拍手]